- Hey, what's up?
I'm Freddie.
And today I'm gonna be
making peach cobbler.
This recipe comes
from my best friend Tori's mom,
Cheryl Tucker,
lovingly known as Mama T.
Mama T would kill me if
I used canned peaches,
but peaches are not in season right now
and this is the only option.
Usually, if I were to ask
her to make peach cobbler
not in season, she would refuse.
So, when I first asked, she
was hesitant and I was like,
she actually really may
not give me this recipe.
And then, of course, a day later
she had it all written
out for me and ready to go
in the cutest way possible.
I knew she was eventually
gonna give me something,
but I didn't think she was
gonna give me the exact recipe.
This is the first time I'm
ever even really knowing
all that goes into it,
because she kicks us out of the kitchen.
So, there's a core group of
people that she makes it for,
and we don't even have to ask for it.
If she knows we're gonna
be home or in the area
she will make sure that peach cobbler
is at her house waiting for us.
It's great because
usually when you think about peach cobbler
you think of dessert,
but we'll just go over to her house
just to eat peach cobbler.
Like, there's no dinner.
Sometimes there's dinner to precede,
but usually the peach
cobbler is the main dish.
The best part about making the recipe
is seeing how simple it actually is
and that a majority of the ingredients
that she puts in are just love, laughter,
and just being an awesome mother figure.
She has so much heart.
She's so fun.
She's like the most free-spirited
woman I've ever met.
I've always said,
I hope I'm the type of
woman and mom that she is.
So, I don't go back home too often,
and cooking this really
brought me back to that place,
and I felt a really strong
connection to her and to home.
It smells very sweet,
it smells very peachy,
and it just smells like home.
Mama T, thank you so much
for sharing your beloved recipe with me.
I hope I made you proud!
Much love in.
Much love out.
- [Man] Oh, yes!
(upbeat percussion music)